Hello everybody, welcome in, welcome in, welcome in, welcome
in, welcome in.
Howdy, howdy, Alan Wake.
That was not me this morning.
Oh my gosh.
Hold on.
I have to explain my like whole.
It was like.
Yeah.
I was up really late the night before.
Because I was watching Doki finish Metal Gear Solid Delta.
So I didn't get to sleep until like almost 5 a.m.
for me.
And I woke up.
I woke up.
Okay.
This is how silly it was.
okay because not everybody is gonna have twitter right so me
howdy minto you're the six to our seven hope it feel better
thanks brian that didn't make me feel better i'm just
kidding thank you so much for the super chat thank you thank
you thank you alan wake a w flip it around wicked wish hello
miito and i was like you everyone on the east stay safe and
warm this weekend yes Yes, I'm kind of scared, you guys.
What if I lose power?
What if my maid cafe...
It's already pretty abandoned.
It's, like, pretty rickety.
Oh, gosh.
I'm scared.
Everybody on the East Coast, please stay warm, for real.
Your maid cafe needs power.
Where do you think I stream from?
I know it's a little late, but I wanted to say the your song
with A1 is absolutely fantastic.
Can't believe my Oshi teamed with my favorite Toll Music
Circle.
Oh my gosh, thank you, Waylord.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you listened to it.
You liked it.
Thank you.
Everybody, good luck.
I woke up this morning and I was like, first of all, I was
like I very rarely wake up and don't know where I am.
not me either after staying up to 5 a.m.
to see the end of doki mgs no i i woke up and i was like did
i float out of my maid cafe again where am i it was that bad
it was really bad and then i thought it was saturday for me
and i was like oh no what was i thinking why would i put
alan wake right before the densetsu collab today i'm such an
idiot why didn't i do why did i do that and so i checked my
phone which has my calendar on it and and it said for
saturday it said leave it alone the game that's on my
schedule And I was like, oh, no, that's what I must have
meant to put.
And I put
Amai's calendar.
It literally said, clearly it's Saturday in my brain.
I was so convinced that it's Saturday.
And I was like, I didn't play Alan Wake yesterday.
So I'm playing Alan Wake today.
And so I made a tweet.
I was like, guys, I'm so sorry.
I was so silly putting Alan Wake because I was like, you
know, obviously i scheduled it the way that i did because i
knew that how fast i've been playing i would not be able to
finish the chapter before the densetsu collab so i scheduled
for friday for my time instead of saturday which i usually
do and so i was like oh my gosh why did i do that i knew it
was gonna take too long and so i tweeted i tweeted i was
like i'm sorry guys i can't play alan wake of the 10 sets to
collab and you know what kind of bothers me there were too
many replies of people being like we understand me and
it wasn't until after i was like waking up a little bit more
you guys are too nice instead of being like uh dubby it's
friday not saturday you guys should have been like um idiot
what are you talking about it's friday not saturday stupid
and so i was like oh my gosh it's it's friday i woke up a
little bit more i was like wait a second it's friday and
then i got really confused because i was like what did i
schedule for saturday for what it's worth the confusion
caused from your tweet kind of shocked me awake and it's a
some things I was I was like oh my gosh am I okay I was I
was not I was so delirious this morning it's crazy so
somebody take my phone away if I'm that delirious then I am
tweeting sorry for being nice like yeah it's your fault for
being too nice I once woke up picked up my phone weird
thought I said 8 panicked did really tough homework I'd
forgot finished at 7 it said 3 a.m.
earlier and the homework was at do till next week oh no
crying breaking bad meme yelling from the car look at your
calendar bit look at it I didn't go to work today because he
said it was Saturday oh she oh no spark
it's diner's fault so true so true I just have so much on my
plate right now so many things that I'm thinking about
honestly if I didn't have Steiner and everybody else that
said to me I don't know what I would do
but we can still blame him we can still blame my manager
yeah but uh Wednesday night we did have like we have a
weekly den sets a meeting on wednesdays and uh we had some
really good news so oh my gosh i'm so hyped yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so oh very excited excited excited excited
wait a second he sent me something else that i some an idea
that i had and he said wait i forgot to reply to that wait i
have wait let me add some things that i need to do after
stream wait hold on uh uh okay hold it is it an idea for the
super bowl ad close
close no i'm just kidding if only just like mint i do that
too or else i forget yeah I have so many things on my to-do
list and like I'll I'll cross the older things that I need
to do are not getting crossed off because unfortunately
newer more and like more uh pro what's the word like not
important but like more uh time they they have a faster
deadline pressing yes yes more pressing things keep coming
up instead yeah yeah Yeah, so English hard urgent urgent
urgent more urgent things are happening.
So yes, yes, one of the things that are on my list of things
to do are like the finishing the voice packs because I still
have those I have not forgotten for everybody who got a
custom voice pack and and it's on my list and I I think next
day off I will be able to do it.
which was going to be having to do warrior wear but now it's
not warrior wear now i can do the voice packs uh
yes next time we will definitely have a different system for
the voice pack so that this does not happen again so that i
can do them all at once and then not have my schedule go to
wacky world and me not have time anymore but i still plan on
having them out by the end of january It's kind of like you
got a whole day back, kind of.
It is, actually.
It was, I was like, oh my gosh, I can't believe I'm losing
my Saturday.
Or, I mean, I'm losing my Monday.
We go to Wacky World every Vito stream.
Oh my gosh, throwback to, like, my original intro.
Welcome to Midworld.
Do, do, do, do, do.
I'm new here.
Welcome.
I think I'll enjoy your channel.
I appreciate it.
Thanks for hanging out.
Don't push yourself too much.
Oh, thank you.
So far, it's a lot of stuff, but it's like good stuff.
I have a lot of important stuff on my plate too, not nearly
as important as your stuff.
I don't think my stuff is very important.
Well, it's important for like, to do, obviously.
But, you know, it's important to me, but in the grand sense.
scheme of things is maybe not all that important i gotta
record me speaking how important is that chris welcome back
thank you alan bake i oh my gosh
i'm sorry i'm like wait like um i think i could say this i
think i could say i have a sponsor next week i'm just gonna
say i think it's okay that i could say i have a sponsor next
week for for for cookie run kingdom and um which which is
very cool um to get sponsorship sponsors and everything for
the latter no for cookie run and so um but like going over
all the cookie stuff made me really want like
specifically a snickerdoodle but like just some kind of like
or or or I've been wanting this forever a ginger snap I've
been wanting a ginger snap cookie or a snickerdoodle some
kind of like I call them like almost they're almost savory
you know what I mean like they're sweet obviously but
they're like not like a chocolate chip kind of they're like
especially ginger snaps like they're much more savory than
uh than another kind of cookie spicy spicy i was snickerdood
is not spicy i got pizza let's go friday pizza very cool
congrats on the sponsor hashtag minty leaks what do you mean
minty leaks but yeah uh if you guys could you know you don't
even have it well if you guys could watch that would be
really awesome so that i could get more opportunities the
future um yeah i'm like oh man i'm glad to to get the
sponsor it's all going towards my move it's all going
towards my move so yeah neither no matter what thank you
apple dress thank you but that's obviously not what we're
talking about um today so
oatmeal cookie and i don't i don't know
something up with the super chat stream lab notice i don't
know are they not showing up oh are
they not showing up oh yeah what the heck they're not we
didn't get like a big
Hold on, let me refresh it.
Refresh.
If that helps.
Waiting for you to be sponsored for a spicy game.
That would be pretty fun.
Next scene!
Thank you!
Watch Takedokie Play MGS really threw you for a loophole.
Thanks so much for joining in.
I'm making such a fun and memorable experience.
Thank you, Next scene, for...
Letting it happen, it's all thanks to you that it happened.
I was talking to her after about it too, just a little bit
because we were both exhausted.
But it was so, oh my gosh, she really liked it.
She really, she really appreciated kind of the same things
that I appreciate about the game where it's very serious,
where it needs to be, and very funny, where when it's funny,
it's just all around goofy, but also...
It hits, she really got hit by the ending.
So I was like,
did you have a favorite part?
I think she said her favorite part being the, wait, I can't
remember what she said on, I was so delirious.
I can't remember if she said on stream or not, but it was
the crocodile hat interfering with the scene with Oz a lot.
hopped up out of the bed and turned her swag on yeah Jarvis
crank my swag to 100
it was so funny every time I don't I think I hope that it
kind of like marinates with her a little bit and she like
wants to know more and ends up playing some of the other
games I hope I hope I went to Minto in NSW Australia the
other day i didn't realize how much of an impact you had you
had your own grocery and school and mall and church and
daycare and the people of minto the people of minto minto
mean
church of minto i know where i'm retiring
wow Mime, mime, mime, minto.
Aibu must gather there.
Where was I thinking?
I was like, there was a place that I was thinking the other
day.
I was like, oh my gosh, I wanna have an Aibu meet up here.
Wait, I can't remember.
No.
Wait, no, I was like, oh my gosh.
I wanna bring this up and say, Aibu meet up at this place.
What is it?
I can't remember.
Oh my gosh, I just realized you guys have not been able to
hear the game this entire time.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, jeez.
I might be a little...
Hello today.
Oh!
Cat's up, thank you!
I hope the stream goes well.
I think this chapter might be your favorite.
Oh, I'm excited.
Thanks for playing my favorite game, Alan Wake.
It was quite the journey seeing you read the game and you
remember to stay hydrated.
Have fun.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for the Akasupa.
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
Is this chapter long?
Minto, but then spiders and kangaroos.
Kangaroos are fine.
You gotta worry about them drop bears.
Not as long as last time.
I was wondering if maybe of chapters 5, 6 we endurance or
something.
Maybe I will do that next Friday.
And then there's the DLC chapters.
I don't know if I have those.
But...
Uh...
5, 6...
Um, I wonder how long those are, I wonder.
Oh, they come with the remaster.
Oh, they should be in the remaster.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Five Seeks.
They're the episodes on the main menu.
Is it letting me...
Oh!
Oh, special one and special two!
because maybe I could get them in one shot as well we do
five six and then we do DLC DLC is not long oh awesome I'm
happy to endurance it each one is about an hour oh easy
cool thanks guys sorry I'm always asking questions cool then
oh my Should we get into chapter four?
I'm so excited.
You guys say that I would like this chapter so much.
Yippee!
I'm excited.
And then Alan Wake.
After, well, let's not talk about after Alan Wake.
We still have quite a bit to get through, so.
Yee-yee-yee-yee.
No big we like to help.
I don't know what I would do without you guys sometimes,
man.
If I play something and I'm like...
Chad.
You guys know everything.
Aibu, Aibu,
Aibu!
Help me!
Help me, Aibu!
Oh my gosh, that would make a great like song title.
Okay!
I'm currently stuck at sea.
I saw your picture!
On Twitter that you posted with the cruise and the Minto to
go.
I've been in fishing boats before this, but this is taking
while to get used to i don't know how you're able to handle
the drake pass strong mink have fun waking thank you have a
good trip donkey help me aiding boo yeah yeah help me i boo
that'll be such a cute song title oh my gosh i listened to
maybe i'm influenced by norissa's song oh my gosh her like
her iosis song that came out oh it's so good oh yes they
never miss oh they're so good excited for that i will help
me voice back it's just me saying help me in like various
ways help me help me help me help me help me still have to
listen it's so it's so fun it's a really fun song i'm a big
fan i was i listening i listened to the english version
first and then i immediately went and listened to the
japanese one
Yeah.
So, fun, fun, fun.
I was talking to somebody else about about Iosis and seeing
if they could do music.
So, when I saw that, when I saw, it was Arm.
Arm that did Narissa's song?
Help me step boo, I'm stuck.
Do you have a preference between the two versions?
Not really.
I think they're both really great.
But, uh, maybe.
Maybe Minto Ios' song one day in the future.
I would love to have that too.
Because it's so fun.
Yeah, they're both both really great.
Narissa always drops banger.
She does.
This one really cool thing.
i'm so grateful that i'm able to do is work with so many
artists and stuff that i love you know like oh my gosh you
know loving toho over 10 years ago it's like i would have
never thought 10 years ago that i would have i mean
obviously i'm not but even with like a wine and everything i
never would have known i never would have thought that i
would get such an opportunity it's honestly like man it's so
it's so crazy it's something that i don't think i'll ever
ever ever ever get used to it's something that is just um i
it's the it's the most like amazing feeling do you remember
what got you into toho
kind of silly actually like it wasn't even well I did
eventually get into the games but I would frequent a certain
image board site called Don Boru and I would be like I would
be like what what are all these why are there always there
was always Toho art we know I know you guys know I know you
guys know but like just seeing like constant flow of art and
like the characters were so cute and I was just like wow
what is this like Toho project huh huh I Oh, it's so funny.
Is the stream just starting or ending?
Just starting!
I think.
Same and with Azure Lane 2.
I mean, I go on Donburu, like, probably way too often.
But, like, I'm also, like, going for inspiration.
It's a market research.
And also, I have a tab open always for...
Koharu.
And so I just just go and I look.
I'd be shocked if most people haven't gotten into Toho like
that.
Honestly, well, back in the day probably, right?
Looking at the earliest entries of pools on Damburu, you
find they are mostly Toho.
Exactly!
Exactly.
Nira, welcome back.
Thank you.
No research purposes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, That's like one thing that I really love about it is
because of like the tags.
If I, okay, for example, if I'm like, okay, I want this kind
of outfit with this kind of hairstyle or something,
something, something.
I can like kind of piece it together by searching through
the tags, you know, like it's so good.
So easy.
Can you make this official mint dojin?
What do you mean?
If I get 1 million subscribers.
If I get 1 million subscribers, I'll do official Minto
Dojin.
I haven't asked Ayami Mama, but I'm sure she'd be fine with
it.
I say that because I don't think it'll ever happen.
So, good luck.
Good luck.
keep thy word it'll be it'll be like 20 years later and you
guys will be like just you'll be like dust like floating
away and you'll be like see see me don't we did it we did it
one million you say calling my friends I have friends in
high places.
Can we have it drawn by you?
I don't think you'd want that.
It would be terrible.
Wouldn't you want...
Wait, are you...
Wait, so do you mean you want a dojin drawn by me?
Not a dojin of me.
Oh!
Maybe we can make that a goal for 2027.
That would be kind of fun.
What if I had my own table?
At Komike.
Wait, that would be crazy.
If I drew...
What kind of Dojinchi would I draw?
Koharu.
No, no, no, no.
Delta, thank you so much for the broadcast!
Thank you!
And welcome, welcome back!
Scoop again and welcome back!
Welcome, welcome back!
I need a cute...
Where's your marriage to Doki going?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Looking through Mince Dojin.
She's really good.
Culture version of Dojin?
Or rated E for everyone?
I think I would have to make two.
I think I would make an E for everyone.
And then also...
Yeah.
You guys have to buy my mama's Dojinchi, though.
My mama, Ayami Mama!
You guys have to buy her Dojinchi, and I'll tell you why.
One of her recent ones for, I believe it was for Winter
Comiket.
And, you know, obviously this is if you want etchy material.
But there was a...
the the do didn't the the do didn't she involved a gamer
girl who maybe maybe maybe she hooked a certain thing to a
controller so that when she played the game, the thing
would...
But what's so funny about it is at the end of the Dojin
Shi...
At the end of the Dojin Shi...
Because...
She goes into really, like, really detail on how she she
made it right in in the story and then at the end you see my
mama actually made it my mama actually made such a
contraption for research my mama is a freak and is the best
kind thanks for the sound effect of course isn't that Crazy!
Hi, Minto.
Hello!
Sorry, I missed some super chats.
Thank you so much, everybody.
Thank you!
Minto made the million subs promise, expecting it to never
happen.
No, no, no, no, no.
I just joined.
What the hell are we talking about?
My mama being an artist?
Yeah.
So...
Yeah!
Shall we play the game?
Chapter 4?
Pretty sure that there's this game called Ultra Kill that
also did that.
I heard about that.
My name is Ayami Mama, and I'm a writer.
Yes, officer, the shaped rumble pack is for research
purposes.
It's actually already a pretty good ecosystem for
interfacing games with those kinds of devices.
But my mom, she teaches you how to do it yourself too.
So yes, my mom is just so smart.
She's a genius.
Continue game.
Gragi.
Oh, Gragi.
I felt like this was happening to someone else.
Someone I was watching on television.
I couldn't think.
Couldn't focus.
Gragi.
There were only empty sheets of paper here.
No manuscript pages.
only empty sheets what is this the iv
go ruggy oh good evening alan hello are we feeling better
now feeling calm i can't meet yeah yeah i see you brought
your pet gorilla with you so sure i'm calm i get the message
loud and clear why right that's the spirit you're being very
brave alan sorry i understand your I would be more concerned
if you weren't suspicious of me.
I say sorry, but I know that some of you guys don't mind it.
Big of you.
Now.
Why is he holding his hand like that?
We'll reacquaint you with my clinic and go over everything
you might have forgotten.
Little walk and some fresh air?
Yeah?
Yes, it will do you good.
Wait, didn't I punch this guy?
He's Italian.
This corridor is for patients.
Most of them aren't here right now.
Jack took them out for a fishing trip.
Except for the ones who are particularly vulnerable, of
course.
Am I vulnerable?
Hey, Emerson.
This guy likes Night Springs, the video game!
And death rally.
Only half of you is visible.
Why am I bouncing?
Well.
He's Italian.
I'm going to mess up this guy's room.
room he's gonna come back and be like wait what the heck is
he dark
oh can't go this way no
creators dilemma i don't know if like you could go to i mean
i'm not a writer you cannot call me alan wake you can call
me mint phantom but i don't think you could go to a retreat
for a writer's block i mean maybe a retreat But like, I
don't know.
I feel like it's such like a deep within, you know, like
it's like a real psychological thing.
I encourage creativity as a part of the recovery process
here at Cauldron Lake Lodge.
I specialize in treating artists.
I bet you do.
Splendid, Alan.
I honestly believe we can get this thing under control if we
work together.
Wake reminds me of myself of many ways.
The greatest being he is willing to do whatever it takes for
his wife who he loves more than ever.
anyone who is this guy who is this gorilla i love that i can
oh i was just about to say i love that i could just go into
anybody's room okay good sometimes um one thing that's
really funny about
um you know just like sometimes people's uh people interpret
games in other ways and just like I don't know especially
with Metal Gear I think because there's so much stuff and
also like you know maybe somebody didn't listen to every
single tape or didn't hear every single codec things like
that and but one time I saw a tweet that came across my
timeline that was like I don't remember what the initial
tweet was I think it was talking about like how Kaz is kind
of like
um but uh i don't know i honestly don't remember what it was
but there was like there was like somebody else like just
discussions about it and so i saw i saw a reply of someone
being like yeah but you know what i think we can all agree
on is that huey is so bad and huey i think i believe the
theories that he uh killed strange love and i'm like what do
you mean the theories There's a, there's a tape about it.
What do you mean?
We hear it happen.
That's just a theory.
Like, oh, and I was so confused because then other people
were agreeing like, yeah, that guy definitely did it.
Like, I think he did it.
And I'm like.
But he did!
My name is Minto.
I'm a wait-over.
It's so funny.
The important takeaway is that even people who missed it a
lot...
Oh, missed it?
Still hate Huey.
That's so true!
It's just so funny.
Sorry, little tangent.
Whoa, elevator!
Wait, hold on.
I'll take the stairs.
I'm trying to live a healthy life where are the stairs the
allegations remain uncovered don't cheer for that I don't
like the way this bear is sitting all right my theory is
that I see something else happening on a glance whoa whoa
sorry I thought my theory about Kai's being Johnny Provost
dad was wild what's this nature now alan from past
experience with you i know i need to get right into the
heart of the matter as quickly as i can alarm sound the
alarm so i'm just going to say this alice is dead no no
you're in a very vulnerable state until you understand bugs
buddy meme no alice drown And you couldn't face that.
Ben drowned.
You're suffering from hallucinations, paranoid delusions,
unusual thinking, an obsession about light and darkness, a
feeling that everything revolves around you, your thoughts
and dreams.
Yeah, are you calling me self-centered?
Your mind has constructed an elaborate fantasy scenario in
which your writings are affecting reality.
She has been kidnapped and supernatural forces of darkness
are trying to stop you.
Okay.
We go this way, Alan.
I wasn't ready for another shot, so I went along with it.
He had to be lying.
But under the influence of the drug he had given me, I had
to fight not to believe his words.
I don't know what to believe anymore.
You've been making it up.
Apart from the tragic accident with your wife, no one has
been killed.
Your delusions are just a manifestation of your subconscious
mind trying to protect you from the too painful truth.
fight the fantasy it will return i know the instinct is to
resist me but think about it doesn't this make far more
sense than the insane supernatural conspiracy you have
concocted in your mind you're a skeptic by nature alan we
both know this everything can be explained logically hang on
yes i'm listening wow this looks like somebody is going to
fall and die on that thing um why is i don't think it should
be so pointed i'm listening and following
he's lying we saw the dark presence yeah never get tired of
this view very inspiring isn't it inspired lake spread below
us i could see mirror peak on the other side of the lake i
thought i could make out the spot where diver's aisle had
been when i arrived with alice now there was nothing but
waves there's nothing there yeah Oh.
It seems there's a storm coming.
Storms are coming.
Funny, I don't recall there being a mention of that in the
weather forecast.
Well, no matter.
It's the darkness!
This way, follow me.
Where are we going?
Alan, what I'm telling you is good news.
Right now we're in control.
Every time you have a relapse, it gets more and more
difficult to resurface from the dark depths of your
imagination.
Not surprising, considering your profession.
Honey, there's a storm approaching.
you work with after all your nightmares this should come as
an immense relief to you if it doesn't why is that because
i'm lying or because you don't want to admit that you're not
well it's very natural for you to think of me as your enemy
it's part of the i'll let him talk obviously loved his own
voice his words echoed madly inside my head but i dug my
nails into the palms of my hands to stay focused you need to
work with me once you accept Except that, we can begin the
journey towards your recovery.
Whop, whop, whop, whop, whop, whop, whop.
Come along.
Let's go inside.
Thermos.
I see you up.
Who the heck?
Oh, it's that guy over there.
Ah.
Here's the entrance to the office wing.
That's for staff only.
That's where we just came from.
You were impressed by my trophies when you first arrived
here.
I do love to hunt.
Two thermoses.
great outdoors man versus nature it's wonderful stuff yoink
if not real why scary scary scary scary scary I gotta go
talk to that guy Emerson shut up what's he doing I'm a real
bad dream Mr. You should be afraid of me.
Don't want to run into me in the night.
That's for sure.
Oh, my God.
Emerson.
Mr. Wake is confused enough as it is.
Another QR code.
Wait, hold on.
Oh.
Where's my phone?
There it is.
Hold on.
I would like to view the video.
So you won't be scared.
But you can't just decide what kind of dream you have or
when you have it.
Hold on.
I have to pause real quick.
Vision 3.
I guess I missed Vision 1.
I don't remember seeing it before.
Oh well, okay.
It's him.
Sitting in a chair.
The mist.
A caldera lake.
Silence echoes.
Loud.
It's too late to hear the words.
The man, naked.
Naked!
Crawls to the shore.
Like a birth.
Death stranding?
to say that would be a lie nothing like a birth the opposite
he's oh it's a tutorial section ah okay a carcass of a deer
lies on the shore rotting amidst driftwood the man is afraid
beside himself who is he he doesn't himself know i don't
know dark waves have washed it away a blank page where this
horror story will be written He remembers darkness.
He feels the shadow pressing down on him.
Oh, sorry.
He must get away.
He runs to the forest.
To a fate worse than death.
Not the forest.
Please get me out of there.
Get me out of the forest, please!
Ducky ducky.
No more forest!
Dr. Hartman is giving Wake a tour of his clinic and
explaining that Alice's death has driven Wake into a dark
inner world of delusions and fantasies.
Okay, okay, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Ew, that's my, that's my.
Hartman had mentioned that the power had been acting up.
Maybe that was the reason for the generator and the work
light on the balcony.
The generator hadn't been activated, and there was no key.
There's a lot going on downstairs.
hoped Alan could be cured of his delusions through
counseling, even though he knew curing his thermos
kleptomania was a lost cause.
Hey, lady.
Kua barra, Kua barra.
Oh.
Hi.
You're not gonna hit me, are you?
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Alan Wake is not even looking at him.
Alan Fight!
Who are you?
Now, you might have noticed the typewriter in your room.
You've been writing as a part of the therapy.
As soon as you feel up to it, you should continue.
Oh, okay.
What's this?
Welcome to Cauldron Lake Lodge.
We're here to give you the specialized help you need.
However, please observe the following.
What?
I thought he specializes in people to have writing.
block I think we're at the wrong place maybe please ask
friends and family to schedule visits beforehand to ensure
they don't interfere with your therapy and or periods of a
creativity also please respect your fellow patients needs
need for privacy and personal space especially when they're
engaged by their creative processes be patient typically our
patients have long-term creative problems and they won't be
solved overnight give yourself permission to take the time
you need bear in mind that you are voluntarily receiving
treatment that has been specifically tailored for you
engagement therapy and its sister method the flow work best
when you are actively engaging in shaping them if you have
any concerns please don't hesitate to voice them interesting
all right hold on oh explain this then mister the manuscript
page that is a that's a my writing what was over here one
second oh what are you painting oh hello i've painted you
okay i was just struck by inspiration a couple of days ago
dr hartman wanted me to paint landscapes and that's what i
was doing but now i've been doing these things a lot of them
the images just keep coming dr hartman likes them he has
them in his office yeah he's very proud of me he says i'm
getting much better i think i'm getting better oh my gosh
it's those guys from before i guess i'd better start
wrapping this up yeah the storm is almost here look at that
i'd hate to be out there tonight oh yeah it's looking bad oh
that that's looking pretty bad that's uh what it is what it
that's this is looking awfully Supernatural.
What's going on in here?
Wait, can I get the manuscript page here?
Ah, dang.
It looks just like me.
Funny looking storm.
Funny looking place.
I want to see more of this guy's paintings.
So he's just been drawing me.
Read.
The Engaging New Book by Dr. Emil Hartman, the author of the
best-selling Creative Flow, his groundbreaking techniques,
engagement, therapy, and the flow.
Very cool.
Oh, I think I just broke something.
My bad.
Oh, my bad.
My rheumatism is killing me.
There's a storm coming.
oh what a storm what a storm I hope it wipes this place off
the face of the earth and these who are the Anderson
brothers Odin and Tor they had a now should I put this a
heavy metal band in the 70s and 80s let's bring some more
games of Asgard they even adopted new first names to
complete the image of Viking gods after the band broke up
they lived on a farm nearby they are well in advanced stages
of dementia oh they're well cared for tlc and all that
there's nothing they both have dementia i'm afraid that the
rock and roll lifestyle has left its mark uh did rock and
roll do that to you oh that won't do oh i'm so sorry to cut
this short for now alan the power has been acting up i'd
better go check on it we'll continue this soon feel up to it
return to your room and try to write it really is for the
best cool straw thank you so much for the 20 gets a thank
you the after party is mine i'd like to bash his head in
with a hammer oh he'd love to fish out our secrets but he
has no clue he's not crazy enough Not crazy like us, Sonny.
Crazy.
Ah!
Crazy is in requirements, Sonny.
Who else could understand the world when it's like this?
It takes crazy to know crazy.
That's the sanest thing I've heard in a while.
Yeah.
She kind of talks like my grandma.
You're all right, Tom.
Hey, we like him, don't we, bro?
He's got to go to the farm.
The Anderson farm.
Four and five for the game.
Thank you!
A crash course.
All you need to know to get your head right.
You need to find the message.
Here, Sonny, here's something for you.
Gave me a rash.
I kept it safe from these bastards.
What do you mean a rash?
I don't want it then.
My head was clearing up.
Or according to Hartman, I was sinking back into the
fantasy.
I was convinced he was lying to me.
about everything crazy or not the Andersons made more sense
Tom got any booze on you yeah no Tom oh my gosh our own
formula local ingredients medicine clears your head right
grandma being Odin makes a lot of sense moonbeams on the
brain I've just noticed leather patches on the elbows that's
not very rock and roll oh tom just lost sorry Baba Yaga got
to him Baba Yaga she used us all taken from all of us took
my thunder the witch and my Ravens what was it what were
they memory and thought the hag she took something from you
too didn't she that's what she does she took on my wife
better off this place the lake it gives you power if you're
a creator and artist are gone they're not crazy I think in
this leap in the darkness of the lake she makes sure it
comes out twisted and wrong just ask the lamp lady oh yeah
yeah yeah what happened to that other right wait they're so
they're making so and you let her you went and opened the
door for her didn't you now now it was already open a crack
and whose fault is that we're morally corrupt disease ridden
old and stupid doesn't mean he had to open it all the way
god damn it oh am i crazy because they're making the most
sense so tired built the farm a place of power yeah they
know what's going on they know the lady party's there man
you you should go there and have a party they're not done
yeah they're still going that bob barter through the app
through the window i don't think they're gonna stop a chick
in the back of the head 15 stitches of the concussion bob's
dead though leukemia oh stitches snitches and narks man bad
scene they sound like they're getting they're winding down
oh yeah I think they're winding down you okay grandpa and
you go back to your room I I I want to go home okay Okay,
good night.
They gave me something.
I guess it wasn't.
I thought I could read it.
I guess not.
Is that a kid?
Oh my god, this guy.
He's flipping all the tables!
Or the couches!
And they're not there when you wake up.
So you can't wake up because I made...
in charge now and I don't wanna disappear.
My nightmare is the publisher people who wanna make a
contribution so they can say they made a contribution.
And then we end up with mullets in there because they think
mullets are funny, but it wasn't supposed to be about
mullets and now it's about mullets.
And when it's in slow motion, they call it mullet time
because the numbers came back from marketing that mullet
time is the hook we needed to go big.
I think this guy's going through it.
kidding they say it all like serial killers with straight
faces and smiles i think this guy is the writers who want to
make everything from the characters to the toasters talk
talk talk all the time i think he knows what he's talking
about and the writers won't shut up either because they have
feelings too it's a max pain bullet joke because they're not
scared is it like bullet time
and give the writing a shot huh typewriters in your room you
can get to your room by those stairs wake oh there are
stairs wait how I went up the stairs earlier oh this door
here oh something's wrong I'm not myself it's hard to think
that there's a shadow inside I knew this was gonna go off I
can only focus on writing everything else is a blur I'm
trapped in this cabin I've been for days always dark outside
my editor is real i saw her again she's not human it's not
human a dark presence is wearing the old woman's face she
was covered in clinging shadows there's a hole in her chest
where her heart should be oh freaky i think i've made a
horrible mistake i don't think i'm any closer to saving
alice yeah it's been lying to me yeah you think me to get
the story at once and the story will come true i think so
too I think we're just a little puppet pawn.
Oh, you went, oh, I see how we went, okay.
Cool.
All right, let's try writing.
Woo, we're writing.
The white glare of the blank page in front of me hurt my
eyes.
My hands began to shake uncontrollably.
What if you wrote like something crazy out of like your
genre hey wake you stay here i'm gonna go see what's up you
just keep doing what you're doing be cool okay i'm cool i'm
cool we're calm we're cool we're cool rock and roll i'm
leaving i don't know what the chaos was all about but it
could be my only chance of getting out of here we're leaving
with the storm there's a storm coming
Oh, afraid of the crazy brothers, are ya?
Not so weak now, are we?
Oh, wait, what happened?
Oh, things are unraveling fast, aren't they?
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, what is going
on?
I do wonder.
What do you mean?
It's my store.
I'm taking it.
Baby Corp, thank you.
Investigate the racket.
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh, wait, what's this?
We're on a comeback tour, baby.
i swear they gave me oh i'm dumb i just didn't read it okay
hold on zane could feel the poems taking form shaping the
poems as he experimented he imagined he could almost feel
the power surging through the keys of the typewriter it
exhilarated him but there was fear too if not for his young
assistant amel he would have given it up amel convinced him
otherwise he too went away with words
that went missing or whatever but emil that's the guy that's
the doctor the doctor is in cahoots with the darkness Tom's
a.m.
Oh ho
ho ho.
Hartman kept talking giving Barry the grand tour clearly
proud of the place he went on and on about his hunting
trophies and Barry was impressed but he was here on business
he raised his voice cut through the monologue hey Hartman
where's Al Hartman stopped in mid-sentence annoyed at the
interruption he nodded at the hulking orderly standing
nearby the man smiled and clapped a practice hand on Barry's
shoulder what are they gonna do to Barry oh no oh no Barry
is just trying to look out for it wait actually
only one page we can't get that's crazy okay awesome I mean
this bit This chapter is called the truth.
Let's go.
Yeah!
Sinclair looked bad.
That wasn't a love tap.
The crazy old fart hit her hard.
Oh, okay.
If she was one of Hartman's goons, she had it coming.
I could get the key at the office wing from Sinclair.
Oh, my God!
Yoink.
I had to get to Hartman's office.
He had taken all my manuscript pages.
It's time to pay the piper.
maybe you could come out and beat our wrinkled oh whoa look
at the lightning i think the doctor is gonna die on this
thing somebody will somebody will they wouldn't have let us
out there without without it happening to the office was it
in here you're crazy quiet Barry!
Barry!
Why is he hiding behind?
Barry?
Barry, man, I'm glad to see you.
We need to get to Hartman's office.
It's right next door.
You okay?
Yeah.
I mean, no.
The cops found me a Rose's trailer, but they didn't hassle
me too much.
Oh.
I'm obviously a victim in this, and I demanded to be treated
as a victim.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'd sue their asses.
Speaking of asses, that fad gave me a real hard time, but I
had no clue where you were.
That guy's crazy, Al.
But he let me go, and then I get a call from Hartman, that
son of a bitch who tells me you're here, and I should come
pick you up, but when I got here, two goons clobbered me and
stuck me in there.
What's...
What's with a cutout?
I stole it from the diner to piss off Rose after what she
did to us.
That'll teach her.
So true.
That's a harsh punishment.
Not that good.
Now we gotta get going.
Wait, okay, hold on.
What was this office over here?
This is a...
Look at the painting.
It's crazy.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, oh, goodness gracious.
The photo on the wall caught my attention.
Why are they...
In it, the clinic staff were standing outside the lodge.
I knew the man next to Hartman.
That is the kidnapper!
Hartman had been playing me all along.
And then also, like, why are none of them looking at...
This is just such a bizarre photo.
It's like, Barry, my man, am I glad to see it?
Oh, hey, I'm nervous.
This looks like someone stuck their models in front of the
building and then took a screenshot of the game.
Like, why is this guy over here?
He's not even...
What is this?
Oh, are these the paintings that this guy has been doing?
Because, um...
The markings on the tape said they were recordings Hartman
had made at the sessions with his patients.
I saw Alice's name on one of them.
For a moment, I couldn't breathe, right?
Whoa.
Ooh, spooky.
This one is really freaky.
Ooh.
Oh, manuscript.
We read?
The truth.
Mott fails Hartman.
Hartman wasn't happy.
Mott could see in his eyes.
He quickly lowered his own.
He had made a mess of it, and he knew it.
The shame of failure was hard to bear.
He hadn't expected Wake to say he needed more time, and he
blurted out two days, less than Wake had asked for to show
him who was in charge.
But that wasn't part of Hartman's plan.
The kidnapper.
Now, Mrs. Wake, can you tell me about Alan's problems?
He's more and more out of control all the time.
He's getting violent.
He's never...
Oh, the silhouette painting over there is scary.
You're already... Thank you, classmates!
Alan doesn't really sleep, waiting at all.
Can't talk to him.
Yes, tell me, Mrs. Wake.
What would you say to him if he'd listened?
I don't know.
I want to say, I look at you, and it's not you.
I don't like that guy much, and now it's all going to go to
hell.
But you don't ever say this.
No, no, I've tried, but he's not listening.
He's too deep in his own problem.
Real Rose Jacket really isn't a drama.
I'm so afraid I'm going to lose him, and we're not even
talking anymore.
He doesn't let me in anymore.
He just keeps me in the dark.
Oh, it really is.
Please help me, Doctor, because I'm at my wits' end.
Well, if you can just get him here, I'll absolutely do my
very best.
Yeah, but, Doctor, you need to be careful with me.
I'm stoked.
He's not just going to listen to you and cooperate.
He's the most stubborn man I've ever met.
Well, I'll be sure to bear that in mind.
Hearing her voice, what she was saying made me happy and
sick and guilty all at once.
worst of all I recognize the words the phone called from her
it had been a cut up of this just a recording that's right
oh my gosh when she called before that's right oh my god I
could draw a pee pee on his blackboard okay I'm guessing we
can't go through here yeah okay so there was a door in here
Oh my god, Barry, you scared me for a second.
The
thickest plotting is happening.
Oh, yeah.
And more.
Oh, no.
Alan, please.
You're sliding back into the...
Tell me one more lie and I'll shoot you in the face.
Oh, yeah.
Ah, well, it was worth a shot.
Dang!
He caved!
Come on, let's work together on this.
You have no idea.
Wait, no, Barry, get out of here.
I'll catch up with you.
Wait, no, Barry, don't leave me.
Oh, ow, let's just...
No!
Wake, listen to me.
This is a mistake.
Don't you see?
Together we can create something absolutely wonderful.
With your ability and mine.
Oh, no.
Oh, shoot!
Alan Flea?
What the?
What was that smile?
Oh shoot.
Oh god.
Wait.
The dark presence will be on me in a moment.
I had to find a way out.
Ah!
Oh, open the lock.
Oh.
Not good.
Run, run.
Woo!
Not good.
This way?
way.
Not this way.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
The possessed of bookshelves.
Oh, shoot.
Um, is there a flashlight somewhere?
Ouch, ouch!
Oh, shoot.
Um.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
This is the only lamp available.
Everything is, all the furniture is coming.
Oh, I know the generator up here.
Oh!
Oops.
I did not mean to do that.
Oh.
Sorry, I'm remembering how to play the game.
Holy cow!
We
can go, we can go.
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch!
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm trapped.
I'm not trapped anymore.
Pick up the flare.
Keep going, keep going.
Keep running.
Eee!
Ah!
Ouch!
Oh my god.
I'm getting hit by everything.
Uh...
Oh, there's a door.
Wait, no, this is the door I came from.
Um...
Oh wait, I got the flare.
Duh.
Uh, how do I use it?
B?
Uh, shoot.
Oh, dang it.
This.
Yes.
Yes, on my manuscript page.
I'm just gonna keep on running.
Running.
Oh, can I read real quick?
I'm gonna take that as a nuke.
Wait, what's over here?
Oh my god.
A bunch is happening.
Okay, we can read.
Hartman watches wake fall.
Hartman followed the fall of Alan Wake with his binoculars.
When the rider hit the water, he ordered Jack to take the
boat to him.
The spot was easy to see in the dark, even with all the
extra lights in the boat.
The flare floated and kept burning even in the water.
Jack turned the radio ladder as the engine sputtered.
The music was rough and clanking.
My flare in the water.
Something the Anderson brothers would no doubt have enjoyed.
But Hartman chose to ignore it.
Wake was finally within his reach.
This was, this was, uh, um, uh, Yes, the, uh, with the
darkness got the kidnapper, but didn't get us.
Hartman knew we was no creator.
He had no ambitions on that front.
And he certainly didn't want to end up like every artist he
had worked with here, damaged in ways that were hard to
describe or worse.
It was enough for Hartman to maintain creative control and
provide direction.
To be a producer, that was what most of these people were in
need of anyway.
Of course, suitable subjects were few and far in between.
Yeah, because he had the flare.
That's the way I think it was that one scene.
Because he had the flare and he went down into the water
with it.
Alright, back to the chaos.
Um, was this?
Oh, oh, geez.
Oh, can I get through here?
Ouch, oh, oh, excuse me.
Ouch, oh, geez, ow, excuse me.
My heckin...
Oh no.
Oh no, it's a ball.
Wait, no, no, please.
Oh!
Oh, this looks possessed.
Oh, please ball.
I don't know ball.
Was there a flare?
I could not see if there was.
I think we have to wait for it to break the door.
Maybe I could go before it breaks the door.
Um, evil ball, evil ball.
Okay, it does break the door.
Okay, maybe, maybe this.
I didn't see any more flares.
Oh my gosh.
Don't come in here, please.
Okay.
Go, go, go!
How do I run again?
Oh my gosh, why am I forgetting how to...
There we go.
Okay.
Somewhere.
Flare.
Somewhere!
Oh, jeez.
Where is it?
Wait!
Oh, can I get it to hit this door?
Actually, let's see.
Run!
Yeah!
Go, go, go!
Ow, ow!
I'm here!
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Breathe?
Suspended.
Lauren Miller.
I'm kidding.
Okay, hold on.
There's gotta be stuff around.
You don't understand, Barry.
They're very important to me.
I know.
I know where you are.
Please.
Understand.
It's part of my psychosis.
Let's not go over there.
Okay.
There's like a light over here.
Just exploring real quick.
What is this anyway?
Just an area.
Ah!
What's this?
Batteries!
He's gonna give me the flashlight maybe?
Alright, come here.
I found the car, but the gate's locked.
No!
You're gonna have to go through the hedge maze over there!
No.
Barry, I don't have a light.
Take this out!
Oh, no.
Oh, not a hedge maze!
Oh god!
Look at the house, Ow!
Look out!
Holy cow!
Ouch, ouch!
Is this...
Oh, the gate, okay.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna let it happen.
Slow.
Oh, okay.
That should be enough, right?
Um...
Can I not climb the gate?
Right, that's the one that's right there?
The gate?
That's like...
Within... Could I not climb up here?
There's even a rock to help me up.
Just... Raise your arms!
Raise your arms, Alan!
Oh my god, he has no upper body strength at all.
Remember he sold those thermoses, but only in Finland.
No!
Also, I just realized I didn't pick up the flare.
Okay, good.
I have to go through a hedge maze!
This sounds like torture.
I'm not gonna lie.
Wait a second.
This sounds like...
actual torture right now.
Oh god.
Evil guys.
Maybe I'm going the right way because they spoke to me.
Ah!
Oh, I don't know why I shot.
Alan loot.
Um.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Please, uh, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x!
Okay, proceeding through the garden.
I don't like this at all, you guys.
I don't like...
I don't like this at all!
Gosh.
I can hear that!
Sorry.
Shit!
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
Oh my god.
No, this guy.
I'm so scared.
I'm scared.
Who is that talking though?
Who got possessed and weirdo?
I became a weirdo!
I feel like though I should go back in.
Is there other stuff that I should get in there, I wonder?
What is that sound?
Mito Breeze!
I'm freaking out, guys!
Other pages are in there.
Right?
I did get a check- Oh, there's Al!
I mean, I've been buried, sorry.
I did get a checkpoint.
Let's go.
Where did I come from?
I don't even...
Oh, God, I get lost again!
Wait, wait, wait.
I didn't go this way.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Let's do it.
This way.
Okay.
We can leave.
Go, go, go, go.
Go, go.
Okay.
Get out of here.
Let's read.
Holy.
I stared at the Viking paraphernalia that littered the area
surrounding an unlikely centerpiece.
A full side stage complete with an impressive sound system
with all the trimmings including a dragon it took a special
kind of crazy to build something like this in a remote field
when the sky split open with a deafening boom and the music
started blasting it felt strangely appropriate what 10 out
of 10 on the acting but you're not really scared right
hartman and the power failure hartman hurried down the
corridor he had disliked leaving wake when he was surely at
his most susceptible to therapy but this was not an ordinary
storm wake had been riding and he had woken something up in
the depths of the lake now it was coming for him whoa
hartman had naturally prepared for a situation like this the
idiot brothers would keep wake distracted while hartman
double checked everything just to be sure no they kept me
distracted wait no i mean they could never be scared yeah
wait i just realized because i got the checkpoint here
Oh, those are like mushrooms or something.
I thought they were flares.
Because I got the checkpoint here,
I...
If I die, I have to...
Oh, there's graphical glitches.
Those weren't...
Did you guys say those two?
My monitors have been a little weird today.
But, uh...
I'll have to go get that page again.
I'll
be nice and calm.
All day long.
Two pills in the morning.
Three pills in the evening.
Oh, it's this guy.
Oh, shoot.
The birds.
Gosh, this is hard.
Ah.
Ouch, Ouch, Ouch.
Ouch!
Shoot, shoot!
Wait, is this?
No.
Ouch, Ouch, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh My God.
Oh my God, this is hard.
Ouch!
Out of ammo!
What do you mean out of ammo?
Oh!
Holy cow!
Oh my gosh, I almost didn't make it.
Ammo!
They're good!
They're both!
Those birds are crazy, man.
Clutch, barely, for real though.
Holy cow.
Oh, she's the one who knocks.
I am the one who knocks.
What the hell?
Oh, jeez.
No, no.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no, please.
Oh, no.
Um.
Uh.
I don't want to waste it.
Oh,
this is bad.
I'm like, I'm, I'm, what's the word?
I'm,
it's like I'm self-sabotaging myself.
No, not checkpoint!
Oh, geez.
Holy.
Holy cow.
Yeah, this should help.
Nope, we only have six, but...
Mott in charge.
Mott knew that Wake was smarter than him.
Wake had more money.
A beautiful wife.
Everything.
And Hartman said Wake was important.
That made him better than Mott.
But Mott was calling the shots now.
He'd expected Wake to whimper and grovel, but instead, he
seemed willing to fight.
Mott knew he'd gotten under Wake's skin.
If only Mott actually had his wife.
The thought made him shiver.
Yeah.
I have a beautiful wife.
I'm Alan Wake, and my wife is beautiful.
And I have money.
What the heck?
I'm quite nervous.
I'm quite nervous, guys.
I have seven batteries.
We're blowing through these.
I have no flare.
Oh, jeez.
Oh my god, I'm so screwed.
I'm so screwed.
Oh my god.
Why not?
Shoot!
I need to shoot!
Ah!
Oh my god, I'm dead.
I
have bullets again!
What?
The game girl gave me bullets.
Wait, why?
It's kind of awesome.
No flare though.
Thanks, game.
Okay.
I wish I had any flair though.
Oh dang, there's so many of these guys.
Soft lock protection, it must be right.
What if I go around?
Oh shoot, run, run!
Yeah.
Oh geez.
Get him, get him, get him.
When I'm not like...
When I'm not ambushed and caught off my guard, I at least
can be prepared a little bit.
A little bit more.
Ugh.
But man, when they get me, they get me good.
I get my...
They get me good!
Oh, the music's off.
Again.
Did that last one get you?
I hate that we've introduced...
What the hell is this stinking garden?
It's actually kind of awesome if we weren't being attacked
at every corner.
It would be awesome.
The truth.
Barry attacked by a...
Taken?
For the moment, Barry was just glad he had survived the
fall.
He had been separated from Al, and there was no easy way to
climb back up.
The fall?
He told himself he'd be okay.
Okay in the gloomy forest at night.
He would just have to wait for a while for Al to find his
way down.
Barry turned when he heard the heavy footsteps and saw the
movement.
The man-shaped shadow lunged at him from the bushes.
An axe held high.
Barry screamed and threw up his hand.
The world exploded.
Exploded?
Figuratively?
Literally.
Please explain.
Yes, yes, yes.
The world exploded.
Everybody clapped.
Okay, proceed through the garden.
You know what?
I did say I didn't want to be in the woods anymore.
And the game hurt us.
Okay.
The game took it very personally, yeah.
I knew it.
I knew there was going to be something over here.
Uh, yellow.
Ah, I see it!
Yellow.
Uh.
But for now...
Alright.
Whoa.
Whoa!
Just looking at everything is so cool.
Sorry.
I get caught up by the scenery.
No ambush, right?
Where do I go?
Oh.
There are stairs?
Okay, there's stairs here.
It's just these kinds of guard...
Like, when you think about it, it's like this garden is so
funny.
Like, it's literally, like, a one-way garden.
You know what I mean?
Like, if it weren't for all the darkness taken here, this
place might actually be quite therapeutic.
I know, right?
Like, oh, there it!
This place would be awesome.
My favorite kind of video game setting.
Hartman's Sedates Wake.
Oh, man.
Spoilers.
Hartman watched as Wake's features slackened.
The man was bullheaded, no doubt.
Even lying on the bed, he'd almost broken Hartman's nose
this second time.
Oh, then!
But with a little time, he could break Wake down.
Give him proper direction.
Wake was easily the most promising subject he had had.
Well, since Tom really.
Sleep well, Alan, Hartman whispered with a smile.
Let me take care of you.
He sniffed hard to clear his throbbing nose, swallowed
blood, and barely tasted it.
Ew!
nasty nasty oh what are we gonna fight here though it's
giving me so much stuff it's giving me a thermos it's giving
me everything oh my god shotgun in case you missed it
battery
one more no okay there we go where am i gonna get ambushed
from
Oh, you're alive.
Let's get out of here.
Can you open this gate?
Very.
Uh, well, I slammed it shut when the nasty showed up and the
key fits kind of loose in the lock.
So, uh...
Don't worry about it.
Oh, neat.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Oh no!
Alright.
It's one of these again.
No, stinking way.
Okay.
Ah!
Sorry.
Oh, I have a shotgun.
Okay.
That's so awesome for you!
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Ah!
Oh, sorry.
Please tell me we're headed for the nearest.
You're now leaving Bright Falls.
Come back soon, sign.
We're going to the Anderson farm.
I knew you were gonna say something like that.
You know what?
You owe me big time for this.
When this is through, the cutout is so funny.
How does girls?
I don't care what anyone says.
I'm done with darkness.
You're gonna buy me a tanning bed as a gift, and I'm gonna
live in it.
Oh my god, it was...
It was so scary.
One day the Minto cutout is going to be there.
You could just, uh, you can, uh, buy the game.
To make the Minto cutout.
Holy cow!
I'm crazy, but that's fine, Barry.
You got that right now.
You're barking mad.
You are by far the craziest...
But maybe that's inevitable when you deal with crazy stuff
like this.
It helps.
Alice they never had Alice.
She's trapped in the darkness at the bottom of the lake, but
she's not dead Ow, how can you know that I know Barry I can
how I look at the road.
I can bring her back I can find her there's something
special about this place the lake it it does something to
the works of art created here It makes them come.
Why don't you just write something that says like darkness
go away Wife in my arms kissing smooching.
That's why all of this is happening.
It's using my manuscript to take over I believe you it
happened to Thomas saying before it happened to the
Andersons I believe you crazy or not You're not delusional
weird shit's going down.
That's a fact.
Yeah, I'm on board man.
I'm with you Yeah, the Andersons knew about it.
They were too far gone to tell me with all the drugs They
were on but they wrote it down.
There's a message somewhere at their farm, Barry.
We just need to find it.
That's what they wrote down
At their farm Oh!
Oh, no.
Oh, am I back in the woods?
The woods.
Holy.
I lost my gun in the crash.
Oh, no.
Barry was nowhere to be seen.
Uh-oh.
I heard him, though.
Barry!
Oh, man, you're okay!
Jeez, it's good to hear your voice!
I was trying to get out of the car, but the ground gave way.
Man, what a drop!
Don't worry.
Your cutout is fine.
Oh, I see him.
Are you okay?
I hit some bushes.
Didn't get a scratch.
There's no way you can climb down, though.
It's like a sheer wall.
We could... We could do that.
Just kind of...
Oh, there's something moving down here.
Mary, it's a taken.
Use a flare, Barry.
Oh, yeah!
Yeah!
Barry, are you alright?
I'm good, Al.
I'm great.
Guess you never messed with anyone from New York City
before, huh?
Ah, yeah.
Is that their farm?
I can find your way around to the farm, Al.
I'll be waiting.
Nice.
Wait, but we have nothing.
Barry, just wait for me, okay?
Al, I'm not staying here.
It's suicide.
I'm going to the farm.
I'm going to go ahead and secure the area.
You can catch up.
Don't worry about it.
I'm on the case.
Now he's Rambo.
He's got the...
cut out!
He's got the cut out!
Go!
Go, Barry!
You can't do it!
I'm
so glad he's wearing like the brightest red jacket ever.
Harry!
Oh, he waits there.
Okay.
Now we know how to get to him.
Or rather, we know how to get to him.
Where he's waiting for us.
Okay, that's so funny.
Oh my god, that's so cute.
I feel like we definitely could like slide down the wall,
but that's just me.
You think that's gonna deter me, huh?
Alan jump!
Alan spooked!
Alan scared!
Oh, Alan!
Alan, um...
Alan,
Alan, go to the generator!
Alan to the light!
Alan turn on!
Oh, Alan...
Wrong direction.
Wait.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Can I turn it or something?
Oh my gosh, this is so bad.
Uh...
Ow!
Alan die.
Dodge them, ma'am.
I'm doing my very bestest, I promise you.
Oh, maybe bestest is like...
Maybe bestest is not the best word.
I think I could do better.
But I'm panicking, okay?
What do we got?
Walter at the Anderson house.
farm when he stopped the car at the Anderson farm Walter
felt relieved oblivion was close at hand the brothers
wouldn't miss a jar of moonshine or two in the booby hatch
but then he saw the man on the porch and he knew who it was
driving for his life and knowing it was useless he didn't
realize he was crying until he couldn't see the road for the
tears what he sees Barry I
feel naked without anything.
How could the game do this to me?
Let's see a thermos.
I'm like trying to see if there's any place that I could
find a gun at?
Oh my gosh.
A hole!
I know!
Oh my god!
Please!
Come in here!
Oh my god.
Uh, this is not gonna go well, is it?
Come in here!
Oh!
But somehow it worked.
Let's go.
They're like a whole dumpster.
This part sucks.
I'm naked.
Without anything.
And I'm scared.
I'm naked and afraid.
I'm afraid I'm like gonna miss a gun and then they're gonna
summon you know like um Jesus Yeah I know I know that
they're gonna summon the guys and I'm not gonna have
anything Because I'll accidentally miss something you know
Come in here it's so bright Come in here
Yeah like if I go the wrong way you know
Um...
Where did it go?
Stop blinking like that.
Hurt my eyes.
Okay, whatever.
Let's just keep going.
Aw, man.
Alan jump!
Alan?
Oh, no!
Ouch!
Alan run.
Oh, gosh.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, all three of them!
What the heck am I supposed to do here?
Oh, even you!
Ouch!
Ouch, I'm trying to... Oh gosh.
Oh, ouch, ouch.
I was trying to hide in there.
In the crevice.
Not a good place.
Oh, not a good place.
Ouch!
Alan running for his life.
Check for you.
Shadow's crawled over the gate.
I needed a light to destroy them to get through.
Whoa.
Use.
Oh, just kidding.
Exit.
Up here?
Oh, sheesh.
We made it somehow.
Alan jumped.
I hope there'd still be working generator somewhere around
here to power up the old lights by the gate geez I wonder
where I wonder where wonder where the next invention the the
sequel to underwear agent nightingale stared at the past
outrider the man was sleeping off one hell of a night
nightingale felt a stab of envy at wakes oblivion but he had
a job to do he put the gun to wake's head and almost became
a murderer his hand shook and his throat felt tight and dry
biting his teeth he tried again to pull the trigger he lost
the nerve wake stirred Nightingale would have to settle for
an arrest what guys crazy start
I feel like there's gonna be something oh geez something
down here though any Anything?
Nothing?
Wow, actually nothing.
Pretty quiet generator.
You think?
I could sense the movement in the woods ahead.
Facing the enemy without a weapon was dangerous, but I had
no choice.
No!
Trust no one in the dark.
Yeah, I know.
Wait, I have no weapon for real!
We're just gonna have to... and I have no battle.
batteries or anything oh my gosh we're just gonna have to I
see a blinking light right there we're like not so far from
the farm maybe okay we're lean mean dodging machine oh no
turning back they say you're you're done that's what they
say anything here Surely there's like a...
He's like, just kidding.
I found the ultimate weapon.
The strongest flashlight ever.
Oh, I'm scared.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm very nervous here.
Omega-3 fatty acids.
Whoop.
Oh, geez.
Oh, oh, oh.
No, please, please.
I don't know if I'm gonna make it, guys.
Oh gosh, ouch.
Ah!
Oh, I think I'm gonna die.
Nice.
Oh, we're dodging!
Oh, we're not dodging.
Oh, jeez.
The generator's total bait.
I think I got that.
I think I understood that after we started getting totally
attacked.
Your code name for this op is Naked Allen.
as you will have no weapons.
You must procure them on site.
Guns are OSP.
Okay.
What the heck was that?
Oh.
Wait, the guys are already coming?
Did you see him running?
I saw that guy running.
Is he gonna say that every time?
Oh, geez.
What?
Run,
run, run, run, run.
Ah, jeez.
Oh my god.
Ah!
Into the light.
Okay.
Oh.
Honey, you all have stuff.
How do you have unlimited weapons, each and every one of
you?
Okay.
The farm is all the way down there.
Oh, geez.
Okay.
Anything up here?
No?
Alan Cardio.
You would think that this guy could, like, run with a little
more stamp.
Is that the...
That's the car in the...
The novel?
The same general direction as I was.
For all I knew it was Barry.
Caught in the consequences of leaping before looking.
Okay.
Um, what was I saying?
Yeah, you would think that him, like, running all of this
would improve his stamina a little bit.
But, heavy-duty.
Yippee!
You're...
You're really not gonna give me a weapon?
Who's going camping without something?
Game hates us!
Luigi, welcome to Membusha.
Thank you!
This is it, the flashlight that I asked for!
The best one in the world!
The car was heading for the cabin up ahead.
It wasn't far.
If it was Barry, I would see the damage soon.
Everything's gotta be the longest detour in history, though,
doesn't it?
It can't ever be a straight shot to the farm.
I'm scared.
I don't like running without a weapon.
What the?
I'm trying to deliver each page to the right time and place.
I'm trying to show you how the story goes.
I had seen glimpses of the light before.
I had seen it in my dream.
It was a strange space man or a diver in a bulky suit.
He was the one who'd been placing the pages on my path Yeah,
whoa, there's so many he just litter littering
Ouch, oh that's a oh that's a bear trap oops.
Oh shoot wait that means guys are gonna appear
Please just kill me let me start over please I made a
mistake.
Let me start over.
I thought it was a pain I don't have a gun!
Just let me start over, please.
Let me start over.
Just kill me.
We just saw the page, so I thought...
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's fine.
Sharp page, yeah.
It will immediately trigger the guy, so I feel like it's not
even worth.
I'm trying to show you how the story goes.
Yes.
of the light before i had seen it in my dream it was a
strange spaceman or a diver in a bulky suit he was the one
who'd been placing the pages on my path
okay let's read this real quick
the dark presence at large gosh there's not fairly that many
pages left huh spaceman the fury i know i i totally thought
it to hell i totally thought it the very bricks are
confusing laid out to it in the manuscript growing stronger
and stronger moving like a storm from one scene of
destruction to the next but it was still bound to follow the
story and chain to the dark place it came from when the
story reached the end it long for it would finally be free
okay taking it easy nice and slow I'm trying to figure out
which way is the safest to go.
Thread the needle.
There's
one leg right there.
Okay, I'm concentrating.
I'm concentrating so we don't get caught.
Let's go.
Over this.
Ayya!
Oh my god!
It's just a minefield.
Okay.
Threading the needle.
Would a flamethrower be overpowered as hell?
Gets taken.
Combination of light and physical damage.
I stinking wish.
That would be like a...
Oh my gosh.
That would be a great...
Oh my god, please.
Checkpoint!
Oh, that would be a great, like, new game plus.
Oh, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Hold on.
Oh.
Okay.
Someone had left a gun behind.
Now I had a fighting chance of reaching the farm.
As I saw a thermos.
I need that guy.
Oh, the patients escaped the lodge.
The storm raged on as the Anderson brothers walked
unsteadily away from the clinic with the other patients in
tow.
Knowing that this time they wouldn't return.
The darkness around them sieved with horrors, but Tor and
Odin were unafraid.
I love Tor and Odin.
Their eyes glinted with guile.
They knew every secret path, and there was blood on their
hands.
They had fought these shades before.
Blood on their hands.
Imagine having a lightsaber.
Oh my god, you're right!
That would be so good!
Okay, we hit the checkpoint.
There's stuff inside.
Oh, the Taken are filled with the darkness.
Every time they say darkness, I think of, like, Kingdom
Hearts.
Darkness.
Is this Dorma's worth it?
I sure hope so.
Come here.
He put a bear trap down!
Excuse me!
This son of a bitch!
I will say that!
I will call him that!
This guy!
I don't... Okay, that's a wall, yeah.
I can't, I...
I'm angry.
Language, sorry.
Checkpoint.
Bear trap.
Bear traps!
No.
Seriously, there's a guy coming?
AHHHHH!
Ouch!
Where are you?
Where is it?
Ow!
Jeez!
Oh my god, please!
No!
This is so rude!
Oh geez!
Yeah.
That's right.
Oh shoot.
How could I miss?
Ah!
So mean!
I guess I could have missed!
could have flared them but geez I'll do it next time more I
think I just need to go go for it
am I going the right way
I think so
oh my god I tried dodging that one not very well though
Obviously.
Yeah.
Hoi!
Oh shoot!
I'm trying to re-o-o-o- there we go.
Okay.
We made it through though.
To the, to the, to the, to the cabin.
We did it.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god!
Run, run, run, run.
Yeah, get out of here.
Oh, geez.
Holy cow.
That was such bait.
Oh, my gosh.
The cabin was right here.
And they were like, yeah, but what if we got you one more
time?
I could see the car, but there was no sight of the driver.
There's something on the table, though.
Hello?
Wait, what are you having me focus on?
Oh, okay.
Hello?
Anybody here?
Very?
No!
What are you?
Don't!
I'm sorry!
Hello?
Anyone here?
Yes!
You think he's okay?
Oh, I thought those were pancakes for a second.
I was about to be like, hot dog!
I mean, pancake!
It'd be so awesome.
Push?
Oh my gosh, it's so hard to see with the, like, extreme
minimal view of the...
Flashlight?
Oh!
I know you you were in jail the other day I went to the farm
again for the moonshine you know it makes you see they're
not gonna miss it they're in the looney bin my buddy Danny I
lost him something's gone wrong with him it's not him your
buddy Like a real bad follow-up to a real good movie.
Where the best friends suddenly the bad guy.
No.
Who wrote this crap anyway.
Pulls at my collar nervously.
Oh,
his final words were criticizing my work.
Maybe.
Maybe he deserved.
I've run through every possible course in my head.
If I continue like the dark presence wants me to, the story
I'm writing won't save Alice.
It's a horror story, and it's going to kill her.
She died from bad riding?
No one will survive.
Darkness will consume everything.
This is what it's wanted all along.
It will be free, unstoppable.
It used Alice to get to me, dangled her in front of me to
keep me going.
It was never going to release her.
I'm going to change this.
I'll escape.
Alan escape.
Alan escape!
I'm now the protagonist.
This feels like a terrible risk, but it's the only way to
save Alice.
I'm just self-inserted.
Just as much as anyone else who's been woven into it.
The story must stay true for this to work.
There have to be victims along the way.
Near escapes, cliffhangers.
In a horror story, it can't be certain that the hero will
succeed or even survive.
That's so true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll write my own escape into the story next.
I need help.
who will help me i'll make it happen
whoa way that's so awesome we're like a mary sue there
anything in here no okay oh my gosh i can't see in the
stinking house at all it's bad bad kato thank you this guy
was clearly crazy not being able to recognize good
storytelling if it hit him in the face, which it did
repeatedly.
Woo!
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I just...
Oh, Danny, huh?
Oh, Danny.
I just started blasting so I could get him out of my face.
Okay.
I didn't realize I hadn't checked that door earlier, so...
Wait, can I take the car?
The farm was still a good distance away.
Yes, I'd need a car to get there fast.
Yes, sir.
Ew!
Sorry, that scared me.
I don't like that at all.
I thought it would attack me.
I thought it would be like...
I start shaking or something, you know?
Okay.
Um...
They don't really want to look around, but...
Oh, look!
They even tell you that there's a secret in case you missed
it.
That's funny.
I know there's a thermos.
Nope, there's a piece of paper.
My intuition was wrong.
Look at this!
We're almost...
We've almost got all of them already.
For a moment, Hartman considered strangling the idiot.
related an emotional infant who lived for his approval wake
by contrast was a far more difficult subject not giving him
too much leash in two days who knew what could happen
hartman would have to find a way to rein him in and quickly
nemi thank you for the read the rocks hello daplings hello
hello welcome in we're on chapter four of alan wake so it's
kind of a little nutty but
We're back, thank you, Dargo, thank you!
Paperbacks, thank you!
Did you get out of the woods?
We're working on it.
We're about to go to a barn.
Yeah!
Winsey, thank you!
Spike, thank you!
The first one?
Yeah, we're playing the first Alan Wake.
This is my first time playing it too, so.
Lunar, thank you!
Konvaku!
Nimi was...
It wasn't...
It was...
What was it?
It was not Elden Ring, was it?
Yee-ha!
Hi, Nimi.
This game is crazy.
Kristen Glitchface, thanks for the five gifted.
Dark Souls, Dark Souls.
Kristoff, thank you.
Krish Leo, thank you.
Thank you guys all so much for the...
For the gifted!
Thank you!
Cool, cool, cool, cool.
Yeah, we're in the truth.
We're getting the manuscript page.
and we're figuring out what's going on and I'm gonna get my
wife back, I hope.
But for now, I'm gonna cause vehicular manslaughter.
It's probably in trouble down at the farm.
Phil, thank you.
I felt bad for doubting him.
After all, I made it this far myself.
But Barry was Barry.
Barry was Barry.
You can't do this to me.
In the arms of the angels.
Oh, my thermos!
I'm too scared to get it, though.
I think I'll get ambushed.
There's no straight roads here.
No roads that lead directly to where you're trying to get
to.
Everything is craziness.
Wait, there's a house here, too!
Wait, I'm so scared to investigate, though.
Risk it for the biscuit?
I think I should try going in.
can i even go in i know i could steal that car if i wanted
instead
take a look okay i'm scared but i'll do it for you guys i'm
scared but i'll do it for you guys
oh it even says go inside alan wake there's hidden treasure
look at that it told me i'm gonna get i'm so getting
ambushed on the way out.
I am so getting ambushed on the way out.
Oh, geez.
Okay.
Was there?
Oh, there's the box.
Guys, she fell for it.
She's so stupid.
Stupid VTuber.
She fell for the bait.
Look, there's going to be a guy up here that's waiting to
attack me.
Okay.
There's nothing up here.
Not even a bed.
I do have my flare gun and four bullets.
Wait, how do I...
Where's the door?
Oh, this is it.
Get in.
I won't leave you behind, baby girl!
Oops.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Sensitive.
She's sensitive.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna be ready for...
Wait.
Wait, this way?
I hate the way it turns me around.
Oops!
Oh, Alan Waste Materials.
Alan Waste!
Oops, we're fine.
She, this car is, like, really...
Oh my god, just speedy.
Oh my god.
I feel like a crazy person driving it.
The truck was so much easier to manage.
Oh my god.
We're never gonna make it.
We're not gonna make it.
We could take another car.
That one's driving in style now, isn't it?
I was speaking of Dinosaur the Ride because I said, We're
not gonna make it.
We're not gonna make it.
They released Final Dinosaur the Ride merchandise.
Which way do I go?
I guess I follow the road.
But, like, what's this way?
My curiosity has peaked.
I might regret this.
We're off-roading.
Having fun waking Alan up?
Absolutely.
Oh.
It's a circle.
I knew that.
Well, now I know that.
For the future.
When I...
Inevitably...
Oh, God.
There's guys coming.
I see them.
Wait.
Oh, which way do I go?
Mansodder!
Ah!
Backing up.
Are they just standing there?
Oh, no.
Take care of these guys, one bow.
Oh,
you're still alive.
Nice.
You can focus with the car headlights?
Wait, you can?
How?
Anyway, I guess I'll drive through the cornfield.
Hold A.
Oh.
Wait, oh, I think I need to get out of the car.
Oh, I think about it.
Oh, okay.
No, I felt so safe.
Oh, man.
Yeah, I think we gotta get out of the car.
Wait, do I?
I think so.
No, I didn't want to leave the safety of my vehicle!
I feel so powerful in it!
Oh,
come on!
Ah!
Shoot!
Oh no, that's not what I wanted to do!
Uh-oh.
Visual glitch?
I thought we were about to get into a cutscene.
How much?
Oh, another one?
Okay, hold on.
How much further is the farm?
That bug is so annoying.
It's so frequent.
I know, right?
At least we know that we can fix it pretty easily.
Hold on, I'm letting my...
Okay, there we go.
We can fix it just by, like, pausing and...
You know.
Uh...
The farm is... that?
Checkpoint, but at what cost?
Thermos.
Are these...
Fireworks?
Is this for the festival that they were gonna have?
I'd known the brothers used to be some kind of rock stars,
but it hadn't really sunk in until I saw this stage.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Ow!
Run!
Incoming!
Oh!
There's too many of us!
Barry, no!
God damn!
Yeah!
Defend this stage?
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
I can do this.
Oh.
Oh, please, please shoot the gun.
Please!
This is insanity!
I'm gonna die!
Oh god!
Oh my god!
Holy cow!
Please reload the gun,
please!
Reload the gun, please reload the gun!
We have to fight them all!
We can just throw them
out!
Did you notice there's a lot of ammo and stuff around?
This place is stopped!
Ow!
Hold on!
I was trying to get mistakes is there oh there's like
batteries and stuff let's go where did everybody else go oh
shoot um
yes here we go yeah oh okay
yeah oh my god oh shoot oh no reload
okay all right come on come on
Flashbang.
Oh!
Is this the last guy?
For now.
Oh, okay.
See for now.
Oh,
my God.
Oh, my God.
What light?
Oh, this light.
This light.
Oh, my God.
You idiot.
Barry.
Yeah.
Good job, Barry.
Barry, please.
Very...
Oh my god.
We have...
Oh my god, I...
Oh
my god.
This is pretty much how I always wanted to go out.
Oh my god.
Rock and roll!
Yeah, this is so funny for you, isn't it?
Wait, oh, that's why.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
That's the high point of my life.
Really?
Oh my god.
I'm going insane right now.
Back up the flashbang.
Mary.
Hey blues!
I don't like this!
Oh my god.
It's
fine!
Everything's okay!
That was awesome!
Oh yes.
Let's switch.
Right falls.
Rock and roll capital of America.
Oh my gosh.
Let's take all this stuff.
Now that we can reload everything.
Do we want to like Not have the power on anymore though Like
it was pretty good to have it on I think What is this
anyway?
Heavy duty lantern What?
Anatharmus Nice!
That was scary Just because I was panicking so much It was
scary because I was panicking Why are you panicking so much?
Jeez.
Jeez, Louise.
Anyway, we lived.
We made it.
What's that over there?
Lineascript.
They're getting trickier and trickier, huh?
The darkness would not be able to survive one second at an
idle concert.
You're so right.
Mulligan questions Nightingale's orders.
Deputy Mulligan tuned Thornton's chatter out.
He didn't think writers were particularly useful people and
a huge manhunt for one stuck him as idiotic certainly not
worth the flares are basically UOs now I have a ton of them
too it wasn't even clear what the man had done except run
from them at the trailer park yeah Mulligan knew we wasn't
alone the sheriff's patience with the fed was running out
actually though well I lose them all in the next episode
checkpoint checkpoint Alan's see those looks like I know
that's his shirt underneath I'm pretty sure but it looks
like Barry's pants are falling down Barry get about see
dress seller no reason to worry your cutouts good as new
right where I left it I'll come back for it once we have the
place secured maybe that's been my biggest worry all this
time what about Anderson house need to get this thing moved
out of the way this is as far as I got for the ambush I see.
There's that glow-y thing up there.
How do I...
Okay, we gotta get around, I suppose.
Oh, here we go.
Seems like a bit of a fire hazard.
No?
Oh, oh, yes, that's right!
Amphetamine, thank you!
You could kind of set up for...
Wait, you could do that kind of set up for a concert.
Y'all up there singing and dancing and we got shop and we
get shopped by you.
Live rounds and everything.
It'll be lit.
Yeah.
Also, Sayhi!
Thank you.
Last week was my birthday, May I spend this year and next
year and every year with the most beautiful ghost around.
Happy birthday, Sayhi.
Oh my gosh.
I haven't seen you in forever.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday!
Yay!
Forever and ever and ever.
I'm Alan Wake here has something to say.
What's that, Al?
Ooh, I'm Alan Wake.
I'm always right about everything.
And if I don't get my way, I'll sulk all day long.
I'm always intense and moody.
It makes me very attractive and mysterious.
Right now, I'm just standing here because I need my best
friend Barry to carry me.
But that's okay.
I can just take him for granted.
I think I see what you did there.
Yeah, it was pretty good.
You want me to do my imitation of Barry Wheeler?
No?
Thought so.
Dang!
I love Barry.
Yay!
Okay, that was easy.
Oops.
all right we going in ladies first you're kind of proving
Barry's point wait a second though i'm kind of i wonder if
there's any pages around here like there's that house all
the way over there i really love that i didn't notice the
flashlight during that whole thing you know what i'm just
that good i didn't need the better flashlight i'm just that
good at screaming and
Oh, I don't think we can go to that house.
Okay, never mind.
Ignore the shotgun.
Yeah, I'm just that good.
Wait, I hear whispers.
I thought I did.
Spooky lights flashing.
I guess not.
Okay, anyway.
No, I didn't need it.
So I don't want your comments being like, man, watching that
without a grudge.
grabbing the better flashlight and then out of getting the
better shotgun was painful i don't want to hear it i was
just that good oh oh here we're going in that's right let's
go
whoa they did all out they really went all out with this
viking crap didn't they whoa they did so cool they must have
done okay for themselves so how come i never heard of these
guys before maybe this from the guy who learned about aussie
osborne through reality tv Oh, oh!
We all spent a few of our dreams and its soft embrace.
Somewhere between memories.
Hey, remember when I got you that gig?
First real writing job.
What got you started?
Oh!
I just wanted to Alan show up.
Yeah!
Tonight's episode.
The dream of dreams.
That's by someone else.
Jones he explores the endless dreamscape only to be brought
to a sudden stop by a decidedly mundane situation a long
line of people no way hey Jones right listen we're gonna
have to wait until his highness over there is good and ready
oh wow who's that you don't know him what are you new he's
the guy dreaming us well not just us he dreams everything
all of this but wait no I'm the one who's dreaming I'm
asleep isn't Isn't this my dream?
Oh, yeah.
Get real, pal.
You're just another dream.
I'm a dream.
You're a dream.
The weirdo in the diving suit is a dream.
And the girl made of smiles and sunshine is definitely a
dream.
She's a dream.
I'm pretty sure I'm dreaming this.
Well, maybe you're a really confused dream.
What am I?
A shrink?
All I know is I'm going with the smart guys.
And they say that's the guy doing the dreaming.
Right there.
I don't know what that means.
This is like the strangest lucid dream ever.
No sudden falls.
we make sure he has his clothes on when he goes out in
public no chases where the monster is nipping at his heels
and he runs like crazy but his legs don't seem to get him
anywhere none of that yeah because if he wakes up in a cold
sweat oh yeah precisely so we wait till he wants to move on
keep things nice and calm oh it's alarm clock hey something
something's happening here yeah what's that what can't you
hear that oh god help us it's an alarm clock oh it's you
isn't it please man i got a wife and kids please don't wake
up oh my god oh my god
let's see what we got around here we gotta find a way
through the barn where are you good he's fine he's great
even thermos I got a notification that someone gifted me a
sub while I work so have a little something on behalf of
their generosity just paying it forward oh my gosh Ryukazu
thank you also thank you everybody who's been gifting
memberships well memberships are way not that expensive you
gave way too much hunting wait I need my hunting rifle
please Please, a hunting rifle for me.
Oh, I thought that was something, but I think it's just
glowing because of the light.
That made my controller shake.
Thank you, thank you!
Okay, let's go upstairs.
Oh, there we go.
Am I really fun?
Wait, what are these?
Where did I get these?
What are those?
Wait, are those the...
I can't remember.
I can't remember how to play this game.
Viking.
Oh, it's the flashbang!
Dang, those would have been great!
Oh, that's what...
Okay, when I kept picking up flashbangs during that last
fight, I was thinking of the gun, like the ammo for the
flat, like the flare gun.
Oh my god.
I'm so stupid.
Nobody goes.
Thank you so much.
That's why I didn't get there.
Thank you.
Oh no.
That's why I was like, wait a second.
I thought I had more flare gun ammo than that.
Oh no.
I should have used the flashbangs.
That would have been great.
Oh well, I didn't need it.
we only have what two more missing pages yeah exciting okay
it's 1976 madness reigns at the Anderson I wish this place
would have been awesome the head east ingredient of their
moonshine is unfiltered water from cauldron lake the
Andersons feel like gods Odin can't stop that's why they're
freaky he contemplates cutting his eye out Tor runs across
the field shrieking hammer in his hand trying to catch
lightning their songs have power something ancient is
stirring in the depths coming back oh no it's them it's the
it's the the water the cauldron lake oh my god for I thought
moonshine was just really really strong alcohol why are they
Why are they trying to cut their eyes out?
Rabbit, thank you so much.
Welcome back, thank you.
More or less.
It's nasty.
I actually have a friend.
Her favorite drink, her drink of choice is of moonshine.
Checkpoint reached.
Okay, interesting.
No way, they went on tour?
April 11th, Seattle!
where we are april 13th california 14th california holy cow
you go from long beach wait then you what drive three days
to new york for all the way from california no how well
thank you so much for the 15th thank you thank you thank you
i miss pnw but not the city not seattle
Jersey, Detroit, Michigan, Jacksonville, Florida, Tampa,
Florida, New Orleans, Louisiana, Baton Rouge, Louisiana.
Dang, they went on tour.
These guys are crazy.
They're the real deal.
They're real rockers.
Was there?
I thought I saw something.
Oh, but that's what I saw on the ground.
No pages or anything else.
Okay.
Let's press the button.
Battery.
Ring rim.
They went on Thor.
Yep, you're welcome.
Oh, there are batteries here.
Oh wait, I'm all full, that's right.
We're running?
Jeez.
Dang, this is...
Lantern is awesome!
Can't get me.
I'm the gingerbread man!
Oh geez!
Okay, my reflexes...
Suddenly on point.
Barry, you good down here?
Can I grab the ammo now?
Yes, thank you.
Where'd he go?
He already went through?
He didn't wait for me!
Oh,
it's one of these guys.
Wait, hold on.
I'm scared.
One second.
We got a freaky dude here.
Thank you guys for the super chat.
Sorry, I can't read them right now.
We got a freaky...
Oh, wait.
On my...
On my hands.
Unfortunately.
Oh my god.
So close.
Where is he?
Where did he go?
There, uh...
There it is.
Come on, please!
Headshot!
There we go.
Did I hear my name?
Anderson Bro's Old Gods of Asgard, the only characters
appeared, Remedy vs.
Games.
If not in physical form, at least in the OSC.
Wait, that's awesome!
Oh!
All right, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Barry, hold on.
I'm just searching around for a bit.
Never know when a page is going to appear.
All right, watch yourself.
Mr. Wake.
Don't touch the live wires.
Barry, where did you go?
In here?
Wait, around here?
here oh my god oh shoot oh my god not the glitch okay oh oh
shoot oh no no this is what i wanted to do
oh okay okay all right all right all right
the glitch takes oh the glitch really like Like, oh my gosh,
it really takes me out of it, you know?
Okay, nice.
Oh, it really...
What are you doing in there?
How did you get there?
Very...
Oh my gosh, it just throws off my groove.
Okay, we're good, though.
We're good.
Everything's fine, question mark.
Yay!
check mark okay come on all right a little berry that thing
wow wow glitch works for the darkness i know i didn't know
we were playing uh eternal darkness good luck with that pal
i didn't know we were playing eternal darkness and our
sanity was so low it was messing with the game Wow.
Wow.
Owen Wilson.
First not bothering with the flashlight or shotgun, then
surviving the double glitch.
Nice job, gamer.
Thank you!
Oh, we're gonna kick that.
Open the silo door for Barry.
Okay.
Silo?
Is it silo or silo?
See more, see low, see less, see high.
silo okay thank you oh gosh who am i facing up there in fact
let's get our flash bangs ready which that did help that did
help in the moment so it's a good thing we okay it's a good
thing we had it um up here i'm
good keep your eyes open okay oh it's just one guy i got I
got one guide.
I thought they were all coming out of the woodwork.
I got one guide for real.
Was that a page I saw?
I saw something flashing.
Or it was my imagination.
Oh no, I hear a radio.
Wait, there is something.
Oh, that's what...
Wait, I hear a radio though.
Is it above me?
Where's it in here?
Is it up?
Where is the ladder?
Minto blind.
Oh, there it is.
Hold on.
Minto blind.
Minto climb.
Alan climb.
There it is.
Oh.
Oh, just a little.
in case you didn't get it before.
That's funny.
I guess I didn't really need it.
But look behind you.
As you regular listeners know, I tend to work through the
night.
I'm not the only one.
Deputies Mulligan and Thornton are taking a couple of
moments off their busy schedule to join me here in the
studio.
Boys, how busy are you now?
Deerfest is almost here, isn't it?
I bet that keeps you in business.
Pretty busy, yeah.
Actually, Pat, we've been real busy with other stuff.
Which concerns an ongoing investigation.
We can't talk about that, Thornton.
I wasn't going to say anything.
I was just saying we got, you know, other ions to fry.
And how would you compare your workload to last years?
Things have seemed relatively peaceful to me, but people do
tend to get a little wild this time of year.
Oh, it's wild, Pat.
It's pretty wild.
There's been all sorts of trouble this year.
Vandalism, fighting, public disturbances.
A lot of people gone missing too.
Yeah, yeah, it's pretty much the usual stuff, Pat.
Just, you know, a lot more of it.
Oh.
Not people going missing.
The Steerfest get wilder every year.
People seem to be more drunk, at least, or they start
earlier, and younger.
And younger?
Oh no!
It's definitely not just you, Pat, but definitely, Pat.
Hey, I'm talking here, Thornton.
Wow.
Not just me.
Oh, yeah.
yeah yeah it's wilder pat but actually most of the trouble
seems to be coming from grown men people who ought to know
better you know kids are doing not the grown-ups that's nice
to hear at least boys i want to thank you for stopping by
i'll let you get back to your patrol sure thing pat yeah
sure thing pat the fact that like that um we know it's like
what's the word that people are actually going missing and
stuff like should should tell uh should tell Alan that he's
like he wasn't crazy you know the elevator was dead I'd have
to get some power to it first okay power time start it up
boys deer fest is crazy wait is this a cable car no it's an
elevator it's gonna go down it's not gonna go across yeah
okay i could see the building that had to be the anderson's
home on the other side of the field it wasn't far now i
wasn't worried about trusting the ramblings of two burned
out geriatric wrecks they had the goods i gotta check for it
what about barry
what about barry Oh no.
Oh no.
Are you going to come alive?
Please say no.
There's so much in here.
Oh, okay.
We're good.
Oh, geez.
Um.
What a nice open field.
Oh.
I knew it.
I knew it!
It didn't even give me a chance to move.
Oh geez.
What?
Why didn't that work?
Yeah, friendly fire.
I don't even know if this is... Oh my god, my game is
lagging for some reason.
I don't even know if this is working.
Oh, oh my god.
Friendly fire!
Do I need to get him to bust this open?
Defeat the harvester.
Oh, you always were a kidder.
You always were a kidder!
Oh my gosh.
Ouch.
No, please.
Let's go with the flares.
Go on with the T.
Assist kill.
Out of the way!
Oh, I definitely tried to dodge that.
And the slow-mo threw off my crew.
Oh my gosh, please.
Oh my god.
That was close.
I don't know, it was a close one.
Holy cow.
I need to figure out how to defeat this guy.
Run!
Yeah, get your own guys.
Holy, holy, holy, holy, holy.
I feel like I need to have him open the door, but maybe I'm
overthinking it.
Where do I... where do I... oh, like here.
Oh, come on, come on, come on.
No, no, no, no, I'm working.
I'm working.
Mommy is working.
Oh, shit.
Please.
I didn't see the third guy.
Get me out of the way.
Please.
I don't think you can dodge him.
Oh, my God.
I think I just have to take him out and not...
Oh.
Just have to take out the...
the first second though that was so BS I was I hadn't even
moved out of the way and he was already like yeah I'm gonna
take you out now is there some good juke's though oh thank
you
okay you've got to be kidding me at least finally I'm not in
the range oh my god yes I am
this like really lags my game is kind of crazy
I'm sick of your bullshit.
Crazy.
Yes, good, good, good.
Oh, I tried to...
Like...
I don't know what I tried to do.
He's so close!
Yeah!
Right in the face.
Right in the kisser.
At least I'm far away from him.
65 pigs in the world.
Alan's fighting Metal Gear.
I know, right?
I'm coming for you.
Yeah!
Are you...
Are you his friend or whatever the guy's name was?
Oh.
There are 65 pigs in the world.
Yippee!
Second round wasn't so bad!
Good job, team!
There are 65 pigs in the world.
Please let me climb this.
I don't...
I guess I did the go over there.
to bust through that door right there.
I hit...
Can I not open this?
I'm so confused.
It doesn't look...
It doesn't look like it's sealed or anything.
What is this?
Uh, Al?
Is that you out there, buddy?
I had to find a key to get better.
out yeah it's me hang on I'll try to find a key to get the
door open oh no game
says get Barry first yeah
working on it oh there it is oh my god my eyes come on Al
open the door already seriously I don't like it in here I'm
working on it
I'm scared.
Am I going to get ambushed?
Oh, wow.
That was the fastest unlock ever.
Hey, let's go, man.
Okay.
I was being punished for exploring.
Omega-3 fatty acids are good for the heart.
Oh.
Sorry.
Hey, I think that's the form on the other side of the field.
We're almost there.
It hasn't been the farm?
This entire time?
We should feel right at home then.
Nuts.
I think I see the farm finally.
Yeah, did it seem that heavy?
Come on, one more gig.
Let's do this thing.
Old gods know the truth.
Interesting.
Anything else around here?
All right, let's just go in.
Get to the Anderson house.
Oh.
The lights are out.
I guess we better check the fuse box.
They also don't lock their doors.
Not the...
Can I pick up the rockets?
Dang.
Look, they have like a record and a gold record and
everything.
Oh my gosh, Barry, you scared the heck out of me.
Let's find the fuse box.
Examine?
downstairs was out but I was sure I could fix that at the
fuse box yes these guys were really popular oh nice what the
helly berry no he's not Halleberry their house is like so
normal all things considered I okay I you know what I I gave
the forest, I gave the woods a lot of flack, but being in
these tight spaces with the, with the strongest flashlight
in the world is tough.
Everything is either completely dark or completely like, I'm
getting flashbanged.
It's one or the other.
You know, this place looks kind of lived it.
I thought the Andersons were in the booby hatch.
All gods know the true.
Wait, they didn't get to finish it.
You coming upstairs?
Okay, I feel safer with you around, Barry.
Don't ask why.
I just do.
Oh!
Manage crepe, page.
Is this the last one?
For this chapter?
Oh, oh, there's still one point at the bottom.
The mystery of the missing week.
Oh, yeah!
Alice's screams rang in the stillness of the night.
myself run toward the cabin flashlight in my hand i followed
my past self i was an out-of-body observer a time traveler
and a crazy i missed one outside this was the beginning the
night alice had disappeared the mystery of what had happened
during the missing week was about to reveal itself exciting
fuse box upstairs look i don't know i'm just looking
anywhere Yes, it's upstairs even.
Look at that.
Oh, Barry, you want to come in here?
Oh, he's not even going to come over.
Wait, should I...
Wait, the one that I missed, is it...
Am I still able to get this very bottom one or no?
Obviously, I know I can't get this one.
It has to be on hard mode, but...
Do you think there's...
Is it close by?
Am I still able to get it if anybody knows?
Because I'll go...
I'll go try and get it.
Stop bringing up berry, not kiss berry!
No!
That's not what I said!
I saw something shiny just outside the house.
Let me see.
I'll go... I'll just go check real quick.
If it will let me out.
Oh, it does.
Wow.
That's pretty nice.
maybe like over here
kiss Barry kiss him hmm I don't see anything I don't see
anything man I didn't want to miss it oh dang let me check
from a high place
oh I saw that light up there the very bottom I can't believe
I missed one very bottom page so frustrating usually they're
not like totally hidden but you know fairy don't fall fairy
don't fall oh well oh well let's go do the the A breaker.
No, I don't see it up, like, on here or anything, either.
Barry!
Yeah.
Hurry it up.
I'm scared.
Alright.
Views box.
Music.
Of course.
We need to find where it's coming from.
That's the message.
the Anderson's talk about that's the whole reason we're here
the record play
yeah Cynthia Weaver right there we
go find the lady of the night oh
yeah of the light got mad with the night
the lady of the lamps okay we need to find cynthia weaver
we'll stay here for the night and head back to town as soon
as it gets light hey al lots of hours before dawn might as
well get some rest and by rest i mean drunk is that wise
yeah what the hell okay find the lady of the light It went
crazy from the night.
Now, seriously, because I know we don't get along, but we're
going to find her, right?
And even though you're a crazy bastard, Alan drunk.
The whole next chapter is just us.
Oh, my God, his cutout skin.
I'm a writer.
If I just wanted to, I could write 10 books a year.
Yeah.
And they'd be the best books that year.
No, you couldn't.
That's right.
I couldn't.
But I could, because I'm a writer.
Alan Redder.
What do they put in this stuff?
I feel like my brain is coming out of my nose.
I'm going to get the recipe off those coots and be a booze
millionaire.
A booze millionaire.
I just want her here with me.
Oh, no, he's a crying drunk.
I know.
It's going to be okay.
We're going to make it okay.
I can be here for you, baby.
Oh my god.
Cut out.
No way, they literally passed out on the floor, drunk.
We have Barry now.
I'm
glad I'm not the only one afraid of this thing.
Why does he wake up and see his cut out?
It's me, Alan Wake.
Wait, what?
Oh, I'm back here?
I'm drunk.
Oh, I'm a out of body.
Alice,
I'm coming.
It's all right.
It was a crazy drunken dream.
And yet, it was more than that.
It was the truth.
A suppressed memory unearthed by the Anderson's moonshine.
Where is he?
I was there.
An out-of-body observer.
This was the night Alice...
and I had arrived at Bright Falls the night Alice had
disappeared I had a chance to find out what had happened I
remembered being surprised to see the cabin dark Alice would
have never turned the lights off oh there I am Alice okay
I'm going oh my god I remembered thinking I caught a glimpse
of her form underwater sinking into the darkness this is a
cool way to show what happened diving after her was the last
vague memory i had of that night yeah yeah after that the
next thing i could remember and we were in the car the wheel
of the crash car i'm finding the first pages of the
manuscript this did he get her i couldn't find her in all
that blackness i must have thought she drowned
Oh, okay.
That lady just peered out of nowhere.
Did you see her just like...
Imagine Boo's so good, it unlocks your repressed memory.
Maybe she didn't drown after all.
Maybe she's inside.
Yes.
The dark presence had touched me.
She had dug her nails into my brain and used me.
I guess I could have gone down there.
I could have gone down there.
Oh.
She's inside.
Oh, boop.
She must be here somewhere.
Maybe upstairs in the study.
Alice.
Yes, that's where she is.
You can apologize.
Alice.
You laugh at the whole thing together and put it behind you.
She like...
Oh.
Alan teleport.
He like...
She's not here.
Gets locked in here.
You were foolish to think so.
What?
No, she's dead.
She drowned.
Oh my god!
No, no, no!
It's your fault.
Your wife is dead.
Look at the gamer posture on this list.
You are guilty.
All she wanted was to help you right.
You killed her.
Oh, hush.
There's still hope.
Quadron Lake is a special place.
Here, you have the power to change things.
Oh, yeah.
She's upstairs.
Apologize.
No, you idiot.
She's dead.
Why would you think she's alive?
Yes, you can write her back the story will come true and all
will be well again She had Alice and the manuscript was the
ransom for her.
Oh my god
Dang this booze is good stuff Yes, I'll write.
Yes.
I'll fix it.
I'll bring her back.
Oh no.
I thought you were a writer.
Why do you type one finger at a time?
Eee!
She saw me!
No.
I wrote it.
I remembered it all now.
In the dark, I'd written for days.
Oh, that's where the whole thing came from!
Entitled departure.
In the time that he was gone.
Oh my god.
holding story would make her more and more powerful.
I thought I was saving Alice.
She's a writer, not a typer.
Even with the cobwebs she put in my head, some part of me
had been aware enough to write my escape into the story.
Oh!
To bring a light into the cabin to release me before I could
finish.
To interrupt the horror story before the ending, where
darkness consumed everything and everyone.
It's where the TV bits are from.
Yeah!
But I had written him into the Set me free.
Oh!
It isn't here now.
I'm here because it was written.
I brought the light to save you.
Bioshock?
Big Daddy!
What the hell?
She stole the skin of my Barbara a long time ago.
She looks so old.
Oh no, that's so sad.
Ew, it took his wife.
She's a literal skinwalker.
Big Daddy Zane.
Oh, he's so cool.
I've woken up, confused, and groggy.
My mind consumed by darkness and fear.
All I could do was to escape.
Harp!
The weak spin in the cabin had taken its toll.
I was barely conscious and fading fast.
Maybe you shouldn't drive, then, because we all know what
happens.
It had to have cost Zane terribly, throwing him even deeper
into whatever dark place he now haunted.
And he sacrificed himself!
But he had managed to weaken the dark presence.
Kept me safe that night.
Oh god.
But who will keep you safe from yourself?
Alan Wake.
Alan Wake!
Wake!
You must wake!
Oh my god!
I wrote it.
It's my fault.
That's right, James Joyce.
It's your fault.
Oh, Nightingale.
Whoa!
Yeah!
He did an Alan break.
No, don't Alan drink and drive.
Turn it up a little.
Now the muse she was is happiness and he wamed about her
grace and told the stories of
That was so good!
Oh my gosh, the whole reveal!
That was so awesome!
The music in this...
Oh, into the lake she drew!
Good job, Minky!
Thank you!
I'm like trying to listen to the lyrics.
I'm like, trying to listen to the lyrics.
Whoa!
Oh, they wrote the answers.
Why didn't they do it then?
Imagine, like, they went on tour with this music, right?
Ash?
They go on tour with this, and nobody knows that they're
listening to literal...
Like, like, a whole ancient, like, eldritch gods.
situation.
That's
how you reshape Destiny.
Whoa.
Well, clearly.
We don't do such a good job because there's a second.
There's a sequel.
Oh.
Now, if it's real or just a dream, one used to remain.
Scary Oh Oh Oh yeah
Teacher karaoke song is so good
It's how you reshape destiny.
Can't wait for you to hear Outlake 2 music.
How
you reshape destiny.
Sing this song at one of your concerts.
Whoa!
Poet in the Muse sweeps.
It isn't even close.
That was so awesome.
Previously on Outlake, under the influence of the Dark
Presence, I wrote a horror story that is coming true.
Jagger had been my editor.
Wait, I think I'm just gonna quit.
I kind of want to recap next week when we...
Oh, that was crazy!
That was so good!
Woo!
Wait, it did save, right?
I assume.
Whoa.
Damn.
That was...
Wait, hold on.
I mean, it should.
It should.
Yeah.
Damn.
Woo!
Oh, my gosh.
I'm so cool.
That was so awesome.
What a good chapter.
It didn't feel like it was pretty long still, but it didn't
feel like it was like dragon and dragon, you know, like the
other ones.
And I kind of like it when it switches it up.
Like, you know, we had like the whole walking around the,
like the therapy office, and then fighting the furniture in
there.
And then we had the garden, which I thought was that part
scared me.
And then, and I just don't like being, like, so cramped.
And with the, like, you know, with the walls and the
henchmase.
And then, and then we, like, lost all our stuff.
And we had to go around with just the light or something,
you know, dodging stuff.
Like, it was, there was a lot going on.
It was fun.
Yeah, we had berry most of the time.
It was great.
And our little cutout.
I loved that.
That was so fun.
Clostrophobic battle.
Yeah, scary.
This is so awesome.
You take two pills in the morning, and then you'll be nice
and calm all day long.
You take three pills at night.
I don't know what he said the rest.
I just remember, two pills in the morning, three pills at
night.
Yeah.
I mean, do in the hedge maze.
scary.
And then you kissed Barry.
Omega 3 fatty acids are good for your heart.
And we also learned that there are 67 pigs in the world.
No, not... Was it 67?
Where am I making that number up?
Because of 67.
Oh, no.
65!
Oh, no!
65 pigs in the world.
6-7 poisoning.
Gosh, dang it.
I need scissors.
65 billion.
You are what you hate.
Cringe?
I don't hate cringe.
But I know I am cringe.
I don't hate it.
I don't hate cringe.
But I am cringe.
You are what you eat.
65 billion pigs.
It's so funny.
I think, like, more than scary, it's so funny when they
appear out of nowhere and just say, like, a really stupid
fact like that.
It's so fun.
But anyway, I think...
maybe next week we'll endurance chapter five and six so that
we can beat the game i am become cringe the freer of worlds
yeah yeah yeah so we can do that and um yeah aren't there
more chapters after six technically but we'll we'll save
that for another time too minto finished the chapter fatigue
made stuff extra scary but she'd been brave and crushed all
obstacles with her mad gamer skills victorious she treated
herself to a super yummy meal as a reward then she slept
lots and had amazing cheese d'wargo is writing it and he is
willing it into reality d'wargo we didn't know but he's
literally at the lake right now You're at the lake right
now!
But, um, the DLC, it seems that we can also do both
chapters.
It's like two chapters.
We could do those both in one stream as well.
So, really, we just have, well, then have two streams left
of Alan Wake and then, yeah.
Oh my gosh, this is so fun.
I can't wait to get to Alan Wake, too.
I might take a little bit of a break in between, but we'll
see.
Nabni, welcome to Mambushab Naku!
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Froggy!
Thank you so much for the fine get it!
Thank you!
So it was written and so it shall come to pass.
Yes!
Thank you guys!
For Mito knew it was not in fact Saturday.
Tomorrow!
Tomorrow is Saturday.
I will see you guys unless I get eaten by the ice.
storm that is taking over the east coast so we shall see um
stay warm everybody unless you're in the summer summit
southern hemisphere then stay cool fair warning alan wake 2
is more of a horror game i know that's why i wanted to play
it safe and warm y'all actually i saw like a like a spoiler
free review of alan wake 2 and it definitely said that it
ups the action and the horror usually action horror doesn't
really scare me like it scares me but it doesn't like i get
like but like as for like the chills of a horror let's see
it hmm it's six degrees fahrenheit where i am I wonder how
cold it is for me.
I'm not gonna say, but it might be cold.
Oh, it's actually not so bad.
Well, it could...
Actually, oh, it just dropped.
Never mind.
It's quite cold.
It's quite...
Oh, it's just...
It updated.
My app updated.
But I'm still excited.
I'm still really enjoying Alan Wake, so I think I will like
Alan Wake too.
I hope so.
And then there's also the other games in this universe, so.
Cool.
Thank you, guys.
I am going to go get something yummy to eat.
And I suggest you all do the same.
Otu Minto!
Otu Minto, Otu Minto!
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
See you later.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye.